we all I doubt this is best it's just
you with a giant drink next to you yeah
we're gonna do the girlfriend a
beautiful girl you have to aerate five
all welcome to sexy Monday here on it's
grace I'm here with the one and only
Hannah Hart and you chose the sexiest
youtuber in the land I couldn't get
close out Tyler and Troy have done the
boyfriend tag here on YouTube and after
they did the boyfriend tag hadn't I got
a big influx of messages about the
girlfriend tag so guess what doesn't
we're doing today we googled some of the
questions for the girlfriend tag and
we're going to answer some of them there
are 25 25 question worries of just pick
and choose and answer the ones that are
most relevant to how we live our lives
perfect where did we meet well grace and
I met um we met at a restaurant in New
York that's true called les breasts it
was a weird blind date it was set up
through our friend of my friend Michelle
we wanted to meet Hannah had was a in
having a trip first impression my first
impression of you okay before I met you
a person when I saw your stuff online I
was like god damn this is funny a same
first impression that I had when I first
started watching her into sing stuff
that I was like this is really funny and
also like why didn't I think of this you
know my first impression with you a
dinner was like mmm I didn't have any
impression however when we went to
improv after so I want on a blind date
with her
and then they took me to their improv
show and when I saw you do a brawl yeah
I was like that girl's hilarious and
then I went home and watch Grey's de
grâce videos yeah when did you meet the
family
I met Grace's mom for the very first
time actually this VidCon no way you're
so tall for some reason I just think all
moms are short I just say all moms are
like a little like short like oh I'm
going to fall to forage like my mom
breaks the rules yeah she was a fox when
de magie for the first time I'm here I'm
here
Oh a night for the first time at VidCon
a year before you brought her backstage
oh yeah right yeah and I saw I was like
hi she was like so nervous I'm like so
cute and now she's just on tumblr raging
against the man - the rage against the
man she's do we have a tradition okay
let's think about this one tradition
that we have with mamrie included is
Super Bowl Sundays yes joy not
necessarily Sundays it's just like to
open general stoop in general when
you're super hungover and this is a
tradition so much is like how we hang
out where it's like if there's a day
that I don't have work to do and you're
always like you want to co work yeah
that's a thing that you do that I've
been introduced to recently that I
really like when you're like we both
have to get done but sometimes it's
motivating to be in the same room with
someone else and get pro tip guys so if
you have a friend that you like to spend
time with but also you want them to have
their dreams come true
go work yeah accomplish your goals
together and then you
I'm going to happy hours in the day
because you both earned it if you're
over 21 in here for 20 months that this
has now become the gold friend tag ah
what was our first road trip Rick I have
traveled a lot together yeah what's the
first thing we talk oh I remember I know
what I think it is an evening of awesome
that wasn't a road trip and we're in a
car but yes but I know when I first road
trip was what well we were believing I
aw TV to head back to Vegas and you
missed your flight to drive back with me
because I drove out remember that was
effort that was our first road trip
because you drove back with me and we
got burgers at that one place yeah we
and you missed your flight so we could
just drive great that was really fun
totally forgot about that
yeah the glass last year yeah and I were
sparkling hair sparkle Pantha B we
played slot I wish our Vegas right now
didn't work what do we argue the most
about we don't fight no but that's
probably not good I don't even fight I
think we have conversations that lead to
like we both will like call each other
out on something but not in a negative
way to the point that the other person
knows like that that this is they're
anticipating the other person calling
out yeah I agree I think that the
progression of events is like this
something happens and then weird for a
little bit yeah it's that we have a
group thing and that it's like hey like
come here and then we go
what dressing do I get on my salad she
does it she gets a dressing to the side
yeah she likes so I can maybe dip yeah I
do you get like balsamic sauce yeah I
got like just like a light oil
vinaigrette what's one food that the
other person doesn't like hey cheese I
love cheese but you can't like it cuz it
makes you lactose well I like it but I
can't have it right for one food but I
heard you don't like I don't know what's
a food you don't like I feel like you
don't like bad sushi correct so I feel
like you probably don't like anything
for Applebee's well actually not true I
do love chain restaurant food but in
general but you work travel east I don't
know but I never ate really ate there
when I worked there so now it's ironic
one is there and what's a food you don't
like here we're learning about each
other is good this is good fries it's
good fresh food I don't like
hi anchovies sardines oh really I get a
Caesar salad and they put the two
crossing yeah anchovies on top I'm like
noticed I understand the presentation
but like let's just I'm not gonna cost
how about yourself I eat the anchovies
all right really
um I don't like sweets what you didn't
weren't done yes this is it Tyler and
Troy answered selflessly
what is my eye color I know this because
one time I didn't know this and you were
mad what's that you is that a different
girl uh-oh
I know you regular and you go Mike
that's easy good
you have eyes that are brown and your
eyes are blue sorry Tyler and Troy we
look at each other what is something
that I do that you don't like oh I know
okay
I don't like what you don't tell me
what's wrong oh I guess I'll get it that
all the time
fine yeah you got mad fine um and I get
a Yoda it means yeah it means we can't
even feet get to talk about it right now
this is a eight already so readily it
comes to my you answered first thing the
hand of the eight is just like and I am
NOT not guilty of this you know that
it's just like a flip-flop this way like
she'll be like hey you wanna hang out
get lunch and you're like yeah I'm sure
there's me I'm going to the ballet
actually this afternoon I can't do that
like okay no problem usually give myself
a good two-hour window waiting for the
text it's like oh god I'm going to the
White House drinking I'm glad that
that's something you don't like because
I also don't like it and it gives me
something to improve upon sure instance
I make promises to the channel my
channel all the time
yeah post a video every Thursday of it
sure thing channel flash me nothing
anyway uh that's our girlfriend yeah oh
okay then let's give a bit but this is
still Emma so what's your favorite
cereal um oh okay
I know my four back one like you eat
cereals get weight a we're answering on
each other oh sorry not oh I'm I totally
Brown how this died well I can't please
tell me if I was collecting anything
what would it be
failed lottery tickets so true so true
my my back so much and literally scratch
one off the other bag in bed and it was
like this is a problem if you could
collect anything I feel like it would be
like small leather bound journals that
you've written in thanks for watching
girlfriend tag make sure you go
hearts channel and check out and she put
up a video for you guys or not who know
I don't know
so guess what we both immediately
googled what they were referring to and
that we found out that they that's the
ghost Elizabeth I gate that goes that
lives it out they really know it's true
that door it will not shut and like
ivory screwed the stuff I like sand and
put the bottom it doesn't shut its
literally because something's turning
and opening no I hate it because I the
other day um I had a moment where this
is how crazy I am I was like standing in
my kitchen like pouring water I by the
way good it was like well that was so
good that was it go bye-bye
no no but put the door fully shut and
then if the ghost opens it again they
perhaps always all I got to go wait when
I'm gonna pull it chillin
yeah that shut that sure that opens
during this we're out okay listen
pulled off the go ships heart big or not
oh god I know